Google Cloud updates
duet AI for Google cloud is an always-on
AI collaborator that helps users of all
skill levels to build secure scalable
applications with expert guidance and
we'll be expanding access very soon so
sign up to be a trusted tester today new
Cloud deploy features make application
deployment even more efficient from flow
management features to multiple location
and phase deployments we'll keep looking
for ways to improve Cloud deploy to be
the simplest and fastest way to deploy
your workload onto Google cloud runtimes
with the private preview launch of the
Next Generation A3 GPU supercomputer
Google Cloud now offers a complete range
of GPU options for training and
inference of ml models and you can sign
up to join the preview wait list for the
A3 today get more on all these stories
at the links below and join us next time
for more